more bio prank than biopic weird the owl
Yankovic story parodies movie
biographies of musicians just like Weird
Al parodies hit songs fans and critics
wouldn't want it any other way the
origins of weird the Al Yankovic story
date back to 2010 on Funny or Die the
minds behind it put together a trailer
for a then fake movie of the same name
with Aaron Paul from Breaking Bad
portraying the titular musician it
garnered some attention online at the
time but didn't seem to be anything more
than a one-off sketch fast forward 12
years and the Al Yankovic story is a
reality Bohemian Rhapsody had come out
and Rocket Man was about to come out so
you know Al thought it was the right
time weird is essentially a parody of
music biopics about a musician who's
made a career out of song parodies
according to a trailer for the film
weird will tell the sensationalized and
extremely untrue story of the rise and
fall of Yankovic including how he was
discovered in a club devised his first
parody on the spot allowed himself to be
seduced by Madonna and ascended into a
haze of drugs alcohol and arrests very
little of which really happened to pull
off an epic tale of Fame love and poker
weird the Al Yankovic story has
assembled quite a cast first and
foremost is Harry Potter himself Daniel
Radcliffe Who The Hollywood Reporter
revealed signed on to play Yankovic in
January 2022. how well-burst are you on
the accordion
much better than it was three months ago
Rayne Wilson of The Office joins him as
his mentor syndicated radio show host Dr
Demento with Evan Rachel Wood as Madonna
Quinta Brunson as Oprah Winfrey and
Spencer Treat Clark as Yankovic's
longtime bassist Steve J Toby Hurst and
Julianne Nicholson will portray
Yankovic's anti-icordian parents Nick
and Mary Yankovic that's just the tip of
the iceberg when it comes to the comedic
Talent on display in the cast one lane
that's missing though is Aaron Paul the
westward star nearly had a spot in the
film to honor his role in the original
funny or die sketch but this Cameo never
came to pass in an interview with Cinema
Blend Paul explained that a bout of
covid-19 prevented him from appearing he
said I couldn't do it and then I was
just out for like 10 solid days I have
never felt more sick in my life and so
we couldn't do the Cameo which I just
absolutely was crushed about principal
photography on the Al Yankovic story
kicked off in February 2022 according to
an inch Instagram post from Yankovic by
early March filming had already wrapped
Yankovic later posted on Twitter after
spending a few months in post-production
the Al Yankovic story will become
available for viewing on November 4th
2022 in the United States the film made
its theatrical debut at the Toronto
International Film Festival in September
but there aren't going to be too many
other theatrical showings the Al
Yankovic story will drop us an exclusive
on the Roku channel the streamer comes
free with the purchase of a Roku stick
or box but folks who don't have either
of those could also access the Roku
Channel via a web browser Eric Appel
directed weird the Al Yankovic story and
it's difficult to imagine a better
choice after all he's the one that
spearheaded the original sketch that got
the ball rolling all those years ago
Appel also boasts an impressive and
varied resume that extends well beyond
the reaches of funny or die in addition
to a number of funny or die sketches
he's also jumped to television and
helmed episodes of new girl the office
son of Zorn the grinder Blue Mountain
State and Brooklyn Nine-Nine among
numerous other well-known Network and
cable programs Appel has worked as a
writer producer and editor as well
though he isn't always behind the camera
he tried his hand at acting on a small
handful of occasions and last appeared
on an episode Nick swardston's pretend
time in 2010. apple also wrote the
screenplay for weird the Al Yankovic
story along with Weird Al Yankovic
himself
at Caesar for we are the Al Yankovic
story arrived in May of 2022. it kicks
off with a concert venue preparing for
what appears to be a huge act the crowd
is on their feet as they await the
musician they're all there to see and in
mere moments they all get their wish we
had our Yankovic emerges on stage
accordion in hand and prepares to put on
a show a 1986 track Like a Surgeon
begins to play over a string of clips
from the film while not revealing much
about the plus the Montage does provide
some interesting tidbits Yankovic
performs at various venues dazzles
onlookers with his music and dance
skills and even gets into a heated fight
at a restaurant a Stern Yankovic then
asks if anyone has an accordion
prompting three people to hand him an
instrument simultaneously the teaser
closes with the title card and the lead
character confessing I'm full of
surprises
foreign
in August 2022 the full trailer for the
movie hit the internet revealing more
plot beats moments and characters with
Daniel Radcliffe narrating the preview
argues that weird is the origin story of
a legendary musician showing that he
partied harder than anyone you can spy
Will Forte and the real Weird Al
Yankovic at the end if you look closely
within a few days of the screening of
the we are the Al Yankovic story at the
Toronto International Film Festival
movie critics began to publish their
reviews according to Rotten Tomatoes it
appears as if weird just might be a
critical darling earning an exemplary 92
rating David fear of Rolling Stone
praise her film as an extension of the
Weird Al brand like the artist himself
weird knows how to make fun of something
with affection the occasional dollop of
Barbed wits and a knack for making
imitation seem like the sincerest form
of creativity slant's Mark Hansen wrote
that the film takes everything to new
heights of Glorious Ridiculousness
Valerie complex of deadline enjoyed the
wider array of cameos while David nusare
of real film reviews gushed over Daniel
Radcliffe's completely captivating
Gopher Broke performance
[Music]